dart pyar 2 says how can you dispute the
theory that Jesus is just a rewrite of
the sun-god myth well I wouldn't
necessarily dispute that theory although
I would dispute the just I mean the
strange things about the biblical
stories and let's say about the New
Testament stories is that they echo
across multiple levels of analysis and
so there is an astrological element to
the Christ story that Jung wrote about a
fair bit in a book called ion which is a
very terrifying book and there are
echoes of the myths of the sun-god and
but the funny thing is and this is one
of the things I can't really understand
about the biblical stories is that they
manifest themselves at multiple levels
of interpretation simultaneously and you
could say that that's merely a
consequence of continual historical
reworking and I suppose that could be
the case but the fact that they manifest
themselves as a personal story and as a
cosmic story and as a historical story
and as a mythological story and that it
all works at the same time strikes me as
as pointing to something that's really
somewhat beyond our current level of
understanding
I can't elaborate on that a lot because
it would take us into places that I
really would rather not go but I do
believe that like there's something
synchronous using Jung's terminology
about the about death and resurrection
story and the synchronous element is is
associated with the fact that the story
echoes across so many levels of analysis
and my sense is that when something
echoes across many levels of analysis
that means that it's approaching
something like a very deep truth so I
know that isn't normally how we go about
determining what constitutes truth but
we don't know everything about how to
determine what constitutes truth yet and
there are many things that we have yet
to figure out and that's certainly one
of them as far as I'm concerned so there
is a sun-god myth element certainly and
parallels between Christ and Horus for
example but that doesn't mean you can
just say it's just a real
I don't think that the I don't think
that that's historically or a
psychologically accurate